[Música]
cidade ou comunidade aonde você quer
dizer a sua vida
eu acredito que nós devemos olhar com
calma e com muita atenção essa questão
porque na verdade trata-se muito mais de
pacificar essa relação entre os
conceitos de equipamentos fazer uma
decisão
uma cidade deveria ser uma comunidade
Qual a que é a diferença
eu considero uma comunidade Como o
próprio nome diz um local onde existe
uma unidade comum Onde existe uma visão
compartilhada mas como fazer isso numa
cidade eu penso que uma boa referência
seria nós olharmos para os sistemas
naturais e aprendemos
aplicarmos a ciência de uma forma
humilde hoje se fala dessa biomimética
como nós podemos olhar os padrões
naturais e replicar esses padrões na
vida e na sociedade humana de uma forma
efetiva
na natureza nós vamos encontrar
sub-sistemas vamos olhar a natureza como
uma grande comunidade de comunidades a
interação entre esses sistemas e mesmo
dentro do sub sistemas
compreende sim a resistência de
competição mas essa competição quando
ela ocorre ela proporcionar benefícios
ao todo do sistema isso deveria ser um
aprendizado para a nossa vivência social
em primeiro lugar nós relacionamos
sempre o desenvolvimento com crescimento
e como se a comunidade humana a
sociedade progredisse quando ela cresce
se nós tomarmos como referência os
sistemas naturais os sistemas de vida
que tem uma existência na escala de
tempo muito maior que a espécie humana
nós vamos encontrar que não a um
organismo saudável que cresça de uma
forma ilimitada de maneira indefinida
não é saudável crescer continuamente
qual seria então a solução possível para
cidades de forma a respeitar esse limite
natural eu entendo que é o respeito a
escala humana na medida em que nós
atingimos e esse critério deverá ser
local deverá ser considerado de uma
forma muito particular na medida que nós
atingimos determinado limite é
necessário reaplicar a estrutura da
cidade do sub cidades de forma a
permitir o desenvolvimento saudável
daquela sociedade daquela comunidade
isso normalmente Pode ser feito se nós
mais uma vez repito
observados os padrões naturais de
desenvolvimento não se trata aqui apenas
de crescer se trata aqui de usar os
recursos de uma forma inteligente de
modo a proporcionar o florescimento da
vida sem prejudicar o sistema que mantém
essa mesma vida esse uso dos recursos
atualmente é um tema muito importante
nos vemos os impactos que as cidades
o ambiente natural de uma forma muito
fácil é muito simples perceber o qual
negativo tem sido impacto da vida humana
nas grandes cidades especialmente e
quando a gente vir aqui cidades nós
temos dados que dizem que hoje já vivem
em cidades no mundo dois terços da
população da terra e provavelmente
dentro de alguns anos algumas décadas
Provavelmente nós teremos três quartos
da população urbana Vivendo em cidades
então é urgente que nós questionamos a
forma que o espaço é ocupado e a forma
que os recursos são utilizados e façamos
um aprendizado esse aprendizado pode
existir nesse diálogo com a a forma como
a natureza estrutura em comunidades mas
assim também poderia e deveria existir
na forma de um aprendizado recíproco
entre as cidades em diferentes lugares
do mundo a diversidade ela sempre a
natureza na medida em que nós olhamos a
diversidade das experiências humanas e
fazemos um aprendizado isso pode ser um
fator decisivo para a melhoria da nossa
situação como comunidade
naturalmente esse aprendizado deverá ser
feito utilizando critérios de
localização
nós Oramos as experiências em outros
lugares em outras sociedades e buscamos
os conceitos estão contidos nessas
experiências não se trata de copiar
diretamente a experiência de outras
comunidades de outras cidades se trata
aqui de fazer um aprendizado dos padrões
de utilização dos recursos e dos padrões
de relacionamentos que estabelecem uma
vida fértil uma vida Próspera das
coletividades humanas Essa visão de
diversidade ela proporcionam o diálogo e
se nutre do diálogo nesse sentido é nós
podemos referir que
principalmente diante de uma crise Nós
deveríamos olhar o com flexível e a
nossa comunidade o com Capaz é a nossa
cidade de reagir a uma crise e nós
vivemos indiscutivelmente em momentos de
crise para que essa capacidade de reagir
a crise de uma forma abriu nós
necessitamos de flexibilidade ou seja
dispor de opções de resposta para que
durante e após a crise nós tenhamos
resiliência a capacidade de recuperar E
se possível até melhorar otimizar o
estado dessa sociedade dessa comunidade
o que nós poderíamos e deveríamos
inclusive esperar como efeito de uma
comunidade que se manifesta numa cidade
em primeiro lugar não parece óbvio que
nós podemos e devemos esperar relações
melhores entre os escrevendo essas
comunidades e dessas comunidades para
com e com o ambiente natural é realmente
uma situação que nós não podemos adiar a
análise e o reposicionamento da nossa
vida como cidadãos como cidadãs com
pessoas que vivem em cidades como os
efeitos desses relacionamentos impactam
a sociedade
isso se manifesta na minha opinião
através de um equilíbrio entre as nossas
liberdades individuais nós temos o poder
de tomar decisões sobre as nossas
existências e esses
poderes manifestos na nossas opções vão
ter um impacto no coletivo o equilíbrio
que eu penso absolutamente indispensável
é que as liberdades individuais sejam
relacionadas a uma responsabilidade
coletiva não é mais possível que nós
conservamos e uso dos recursos
Centralizado e os benefícios sejam
privatizados na forma de que poucos tem
muito e muitos não têm nem o mínimo
necessário para uma vida digna nas
cidades e que isso seja encarado como
natural o que se tornou habitual não é
natural Mas precisamos realmente
refletir como sociedade e tomar decisões
a partir das atitudes individuais de
forma a impactar de maneira evolutiva a
nossa convivência social e natural
isso se refletirá
naturalmente na melhor qualidade de vida
para os seres humanos e a qualidade de
vida relacional dos seres humanos com o
ambiente do qual fazemos parte quando eu
respiro aqui qualidade de vida é
importante definir é decisivo é
essencial diferenciar qualidade de vida
de condição de vida a condição de vida
ela normalmente não proporcionam a
qualidade de vida a partir de um certo
ponto e até obstaculiza dificulta uma
boa qualidade de vida porque na medida
em que nós nos preocupamos em ter
elementos externos para melhorar nossa
qualidade de vida e isso muitas vezes
nos permite apenas que nós sobrevivamos
a vida humana é caracterizada por esse
diferencial
importantíssimo que é uma vivência
estética da realidade as cidades
deveriam ser idealmente na minha opinião
um ambiente um repositório um continente
de manifestação da vida como uma obra de
arte e isso é possível na medida em que
nós ultrapassamos Pelas nossas decisões
conscientes os limites estreitos da mala
sobrevivência os seres humanos eles
podem conscientemente tomar opções que
de alguma forma modelam os mecanismos
naturais instintivos de Harmonia beleza
e isso é o papel da arte as cidades
deveriam ser espaço de manifestação da
arte em suas múltiplas facetas viver
pode ser uma arte a arte é muito mais do
que apenas uma manifestação exterior da
beleza a forma como nós vivemos deveria
ser a maior obra de arte da nossa vida o
estilo de vida que nós adotamos deveria
proporcionar contentamento diante de
qualquer circunstância e isso é
influenciado pelo meio na medida em que
nós vivemos no estilo de vida que nos
proporcionar contentamento e realmente
possibilita que nós possamos ir além da
Sobrevivência e manifestemos a vida em
sua Plenitude isso influencia o ambiente
nós temos aqui um ciclo Virtuoso
o nosso estilo de vida beneficia o
ambiente e esse ambiente uma vez
modificado de modo a proporcionar
qualidade de vida melhora a nossa
qualidade de vida individual essa é na
minha opinião uma possibilidade muito
auspiciosa da Vida em uma cidade e que
essa cidade em respeitando a escala
humana de manifestação da sociedade
possibilite um diálogo fraterno para com
a natureza que prover os meios para sua
existência
eu realmente não consigo conceber algo
mais bonito como uma manifestação da
vida humana na terra da sociedade humana
na terra do que essa possibilidade de
nós vivemos uma vida de qualidade
gerando benefício para toda grande
comunidade de vida no planeta Terra que
é a nossa única casa isso seria no meu
entender um objetivo bastante
elevado para concepção de uma cidade o
uso inteligente dos recursos naturais o
respeito à diversidade e as opções
conscientes de aprendizado baseado no
diálogo com a observação dos conceitos
trazidos para nossa realidade local Esse
é um espaço que eu acredito que somente
no será proporcionada pelo diálogo e o
diálogo dessa forma como nesse momento
nós estamos fazendo ele nutre as nossas
inspirações mas necessita de uma
manifestação no cotidiano Então nesse
momento meu convite que também é um
desafio é que para que você tome os
elementos que possam servir para sua
transformação
evolutiva na vida em uma cidade e
aplique aplique a partir de hoje o nosso
poder consiste em fazemos opções a
partir das escolhas individuais para
manifestar os efeitos na realidade
coletiva isso se torna tão mais urgente
profundo é a crise planetária que nós
fizemos esse momento eu deixo esse
convite Deixa essa aspiração e a sua
inspiração e realmente desejo que nós
possamos
continuar dialogando continuar
aprendendo reciprocamente e continuar
vivendo uma assistência que vale a pena
que nós não tá passemos os limites da
Sobrevivência e que nós possamos
realmente viver como seres humanos que
dignificam a vida na Terra e que
colaboram para prosperidade dessa vida
seja nas cidades com a maioria de nós ou
seja como todos aqueles que vivem fora
das cidades e que colaboram
decisivamente para que a vida das
cidades ocorre Esse é o meu desejo Esse
é meu voto e que nós possamos propagar
essa ideia principalmente a partir do
exemplo muito mais do que a partir de
uma mera exposição de conceitos que nós
possamos ter uma vida realmente digna
realmente baseado em contentamento e que
nós temos a capacidade de apreciar sua
vida a cada momento Esse é meu desejo
sincero a todos nós
[Música]